perotta a two-week-old Camp born out of
necessity home to thousands who've
crossed the border with westard Ford at
just four miles away fleeing a new wave
of violence
Hawaii has only been here for a day her
twins were born in a village just
outside of Elgin of 15 days ago
but before she could recover from
childbirth she was forced to move and
says she's now disabled
foreign the Arabs kicked us out her
mother says they said they'll kill us if
we don't leave
[Music]
three generations now displaced by the
latest iteration of War
has seen 20 years of ethnic conflict but
now the war in Khartoum has drawn the
lines deeper into the Sun and many
people who have weathered two decades of
violence have now come here for a
semblance of safety
foreign
so there's been war in that Fort for the
last 20 years why would you leave now
has it
um
[Music]
the rapid support forces was born from
Arab gender wheat militias in Darfur and
as their war with the state that funded
and trained them continues so too does a
campaign of Terror against non-arabs
foreign
here they found security supplies and a
fresh slate
communities across Eastern Chad are
accommodating the influx and camps that
were established 20 years ago are now
being extended to welcome new arrivals
Ahmad
Abdullah Sharif
fatuma Suleiman abdarman
hamisa has been settled here since the
conflict started in Darfur and now 20
years later her family has come too
foreign
[Music]
they've arrived here overnight
transferred from settlements On the
Border after fighting spilled over
they have been moved from the place of
arrival
wonderlu to Gaga now because of Tourism
security because Waterloo is really
close to the Border
of Sudan and then
it's going to rain very soon
the journey is physically draining I'm
unwell here here and here says Halima
the insecurity on the main road from
engineer has made people take a longer
route into Chad only to then be moved
again
but it's worth it
[Music]
foreign
the resilience and relief is palpable
a deep gratitude for survival that makes
even this harsh environment a sanctuary
Sky News Eastern chant